[Música]
soy un friki soy un investigador a nivel
de preparación física de movimiento de
ejercicio de ser humano he trabajado en
la agencia europea en preparación física
de astronautas también en misiones
análogos a marte que son simulaciones
que hago con el autor en space forum
high 6 en el volcán mauna loa y también
investigó ciertos aspectos sobre la
preparación física de estos astronautas
pero antes de empezar este apasionante
viaje que vamos a hacer quiero contaros
un poco de qué va todo esto el concepto
de exploración porque en realidad la
exploración el explorar está en la
esencia del ser humano está en nuestro
adn no y tenemos diferentes motivos para
explorar cómo puede ser la supervivencia
como puede ser la búsqueda de recursos
propio ego o conocimiento búsqueda de
conocimiento y búsqueda experiencias de
hecho son esta búsqueda de conocimiento
y experiencias las que nos llevan a una
transición entre explorar y evolucionar
hablamos de evolucionar en este télex y
es lo que vine a contaros cómo
evolucionamos evolucionamos desde la
exploración para ser seres más
eficientes más efectivos y en realidad
seres más evolucionados y tenemos
diferentes ejemplos
la historia humana como puede ser los
primeros homínidos que viajaron desde
áfrica hasta asia y europa el
descubrimiento de américa los primeros
viajes a la luna o bueno a donde hemos
evolucionado hoy no y que a donde hemos
evolucionado hoy hemos evolucionado a
esto pero esto realmente dista mucho de
las ambiciones que tenían nuestros seres
anteriores nuestros antepasados y por
favor no hagáis esto en casa pero no os
preocupéis porque el futuro está aquí y
el futuro nos trae cosas impresionantes
como esto
marte
y quiero que este viaje comience un poco
poniendo en situación lo que supone un
viaje de estas características y todo el
mundo seguro que ha visto los censos
entonces realmente para ponerse en
perspectiva un viaje a marte
de hecho el planeta tierra puede ser
como la casa de los simpson
y las misiones a la luna supusieron
abrir la puerta de nuestra casa y poner
el pie
en el primer escalón para ir a nuestro
jardín pero realmente un viejo viaje a
marte que supone un viaje de 55 millones
55 millones de kilómetros solo sería
como ir a visitar y saludar a nuestros
vecinos los flanders
y realmente no es una casualidad hablar
de todo esto hablar de marte porque
tenemos multitud de instituciones
empresas organizaciones proyectos que
hablan de marte 2018 2020 2025 2030
realmente marte está de moda
y yo no he querido ser menos de hecho
escribí un whatsapp el otro día mi
colega lo más para comentarlo oye tío
vamos a ver qué está de moda vamos a
marte no nos vamos a quedar atrás el tío
que es un colgado realmente un poquito
como yo pues me dijo venga vamos pero
bueno ya fuera de bromas vamos a poner
serios porque os quiero contar los
requisitos que son necesarios para ir a
marte y el primero de ellos es la
duración porque realmente ir a martín es
un viaje a cádiz de 6 horas es un viaje
de seis meses en el camino más corto
donde la tierra y marte están más juntos
otros los requisitos interesantes y
esenciales van a ser que vamos a tener
que ser autosuficientes energéticamente
y de otros recursos energía combustible
agua oxígeno alimentos los tres
siguientes requisitos van a afectar a
nuestra salud el aislamiento el
confinamiento que supone un viaje a
marte nos va a afectar a nuestra salud
psicológica la radiación cósmica solar a
nuestro adn la microgravedad adaptación
de todos los sistemas fisiológicos que
nos van a nos van a hacer muy eficientes
en un ambiente de microgravedad pero
poco eficientes una gravedad
terrestre
y el sexto requisito indispensable el
dinero seguro que lo sabíais pero una
misión a marte realmente es una
estimación reciente supone 100 mil
millones de dólares 100 mil millones de
dólares que si pusiésemos cada dólar de
esa cifra podríamos formar una montaña
de 10 mil kilómetros de altura
y no estoy yendo por ahí no podríamos
hacer un puente entre la tierra y marte
con tanto billete de verdad para bajar
esta tierra esta cifra realmente
podríamos hablar de uno con cuatro veces
el rescate de la banca española un sexto
del presupuesto de eeuu en defensa para
este año
un décimo de apel 20 real madrid y como
se quiere gustar el futbolín es 863
cristiano ronaldo cada uno de ellos con
consell fish como ritos así que me
parece muchísimo ego y creo que es mejor
invertirlos en un viaje a marte pero en
qué punto estamos porque estamos
hablando de proyecto estamos hablando de
empresas
estamos hablando requisitos pero en qué
punto estamos realmente y quiero
contaros he venido aquí a contaros el
status quo y esta cuestión y es que
realmente los sistemas de propulsión los
proyectos que existen velas solares
motores de plasma tanto como los
sistemas de búsqueda autosuficiencia
energética producción de combustible
energía alimentos oxígeno agua como el
blindaje de las naves con sistemas
derivados del hidrógeno que neutralizan
las partículas cargadas energéticamente
del espacio y la adaptación a la
microgravedad con actividad física que
es a lo que yo me dedico nutrición y
farmacología
en ninguna de esas cuatro cosas hemos
conseguido crear a día de hoy sistemas
que digamos estamos preparados para
llamarte el único sistema que hemos
conseguido que pudiésemos estar más
preparados sería en el ámbito
psicológico donde tenemos datos de
emisiones análogas a marte donde los
astronautas vuelven con una relativa
buena salud psicológica y sociológica
por tanto aunque tuviésemos y
estuviésemos preparados para llamarte en
todos los sistemas como hemos visto que
no ocurre hoy en día sería un salto al
vacío porque porque los datos que
tenemos de los astronautas actuales en
la estación espacial internacional y en
otras misiones son de como mucho un año
en ese ambiente por tanto un viaje a
marte supondría tres años de duración de
ida y vuelta si nos quedamos allí
muchísimo más por eso digo que nos
supondría un salto a lo desconocido al
vacío sin ningún sentido y con muchos
riesgos por tanto que concluimos de esto
bueno que los seres humanos somos seres
muy vulnerables extremadamente
vulnerables a las fuerzas del cosmos
estamos listos para llamarte
de hecho nos quedaríamos como este chico
de aquí pero entonces esto significa que
vayamos no vamos a llamarte vamos a ir a
marte bueno ocurrirá de hecho ocurrirá
porque tenemos que ir pero no ocurrirá
antes de 2050 de hecho estoy tan seguro
de esta fecha que escribió un tweet a mi
colega y lo más apostando me una
generosa cantidad de dinero y que sí
bueno él lleva a seres humanos antes de
2050 pues gana él y si no gano yo por
último porque porque ir a marte porque
estamos hablando de proyectos requisitos
soluciones bla bla bla bla bla bla pero
realmente muchos preguntaréis vale vale
y por qué tenemos que ir a marte lo
realmente marte nos ofrece dos cosas la
primera conocer cómo y por qué estamos
aquí no aquí en látex no aquí en la
última no aquí en la tierra sino con
respecto al sistema solar con sistema al
universo no con referencia al universo
y realmente esto lo que nos ofrece es
conocer también si es tan especial la
vida en nuestro planeta o en otros
planetas sobre todo la vida inteligente
que nos permite evolucionar conocer y
comunicarnos y en segundo lugar muy
importante como backup de la especie
humana porque porque como hemos visto
una especie que es tan frágil
en referencia a las fuerzas del cosmos
en un planeta con cada vez más más
superpoblación más falta de recursos no
en número en mala gestión
necesitamos un backup y una copia de
seguridad
de nuestra especie en otro sitio y que
mejor sitio que marte pero realmente
esto no va a ocurrir solo y no va a
ocurrir como consecuencia del proyecto
de un país o de un continente donde la
empresa va a ocurrir como colaboración
de todos los países y de todos los seres
humanos porque al final los seres que
vayan a marte en los primeros seres
humanos van a representar a todos
nosotros y esto lo que nos hace
plantearnos realmente es que tenemos que
estar todos juntos en esto como tenemos
que pensar y tenemos que trabajar en
esto todos pensando por y para la
humanidad os unís muchas gracias
[Aplausos]